take i'm madison mills hurricane laura
is expected to become a category 4
hurricane and make landfall
off the coasts of louisiana and texas
overnight
this comes of course as southern states
are reeling from covet 19.
joining us to talk about the official
response to these events is
houston's mayor sylvester turner mr
mayor thank you so much
for joining us this afternoon to talk
about how
houston is planning to respond uh first
i just want to get
kind of a brief overview on how you're
doing how are you holding up
well you know i'm doing fine you know
this this city has been battle tested so
many times
over the last several years reference to
storms and
um you know we just kind of each storm
is different
uh but houstonians know what to do and
and based on
what we are getting as of early this
morning seems like the storm moves
slightly
to the right which will which will help
us out quite a bit
and i want to talk about the storm for
the start of our conversation here what
plans do you have
if the storm kind of elevates and gets
unfortunately worse for the residents of
houston well i will tell you that
we had already entered voluntary
evacuations for
uh some of our zip codes that are
further south
closer to the coast and so we issued
voluntary evacuations for them
on on yesterday at the same time we've
set up a number
of uh shelters uh throughout the city
because of corvid 19
we can't do things like we did things
for example during hurricane harvey when
we had 10 000 people
in our convention center so there are a
number of shelters
so that we can engage in the social
discipline and and the cove protocols
taking the temps and things of things of
that nature we have encouraged people
for example
uh to do everything they need to do to
put together their hurricane kits
but in addition to the batteries and
making sure you have your medicine
make sure that they're adding for
example the portable chargers
in addition the mask sanitizers all of
those things so
expanded hurricane kit and then going
back to hurricane ike in 2008
that was more of a wind event where we
it was
uh wide power outages where people were
without power for about 14 days
and so we've asked people to be mindful
of that
and in talking with um center point
utility for example
they have an additional seven right at
seven thousand people
uh on the on the call are ready to come
into for example
into the city into this area of the day
after for example the storm passes
they're right about 2
000 but they've called up about an
additional 7 000 people
linemen people to cut trees trees and
things of that
and you mentioned hurricane ike i want
to ask you about uh
the ike dyke um what is the plan for
building and kind of following through
on some of the safety measures that are
needed to keep residents safe
in fact we talked about that again at
the city council meeting today
what these there are two storms
hurricanes that entered the gulf in this
past week
and of course hurricane lauren again
emphasizes the importance of what we
call either the ag dyke or the coastal
spine
um if for example uh if this storm were
to hit right along the galveston bay
the storm surge uh would create um
an uh um just a horrific amount of
destruction of damage and not in to come
to to uh businesses to the port of
houston
uh to residents you know homeowners
and so it points out again how important
it is
for us to put in place an ag dyke or the
coastal spine
and we're certainly encouraging the
federal government along with the state
to really step up to fund that necessary
uh project and some officials are
calling areas that are due to get hit by
this storm
unsurvivable um what's your advice to
residents who are hearing that and are
understandably
really concerned well the reality is is
that more people
lose their lives from the storm surge
when you've got for example
a category three category four higher
storm coming into the area
more people die from the storm surge so
you have to evacuate
you know that if you if you're right
along that coastline
you simply don't have a choice just like
in this particular case
there was a great deal of
unpredictability as to where this storm
was going to land
and so people in in southeast texas
beaumont port arthur chambers county
they evacuated those were mandatory
evacuations
galveston for example they entered a
mandatory evacuation
because it's not it's not necessarily
the rain or the wind
it's that storm surge that creates a
great deal of damage so
when you're dealing with a storm of this
magnitude
you know you just don't want to wait it
out and hope for the best
you really have to get out of its way
and you mentioned evacuations a new
study is showing
that evacuation measures that have
typically been used in these scenarios
could increase virus numbers by tens of
thousands
so i'm wondering how will your response
if residents um
do unfortunately have to evacuate uh how
will your response
include a desire to reduce the risk of
spreading proper 19.
right and good question i mean the
reality is is that the corona virus
is fuel when you come together bringing
people together
will fuel this virus so when you're
preparing for
a hurricane or a major storm event like
hurricane laura
you have to bear that in mind instead of
clustering a lot of people together
into let's say uh two or three big
shelters
you need to you need to have a number of
them
so you can still engage in social
distancing in the case
for example in the preparation for this
storm we were not just going to be using
the convention center or schools
we were also going to be using you know
thousands of hotel rooms
and putting people in hotel rooms to
spread them out at the same time we
wanted to we
we encourage people to do be tested
ahead of time
because it's important for people to
know their status
just in case if they had to go bunk with
family members or friends or neighbors
they needed to know their status so the
testing was
was pushed very strongly ahead of this
storm
so there are additional there are
several other protocols that we put in
place pre-screening
and then in bringing people into for
example
your shelters to the extent they were
going there uh we needed to make sure
that um
we kind of tested them first or did the
temperature checks
make sure they had them their mass make
sure they had protocols
social distance themselves even in
evacuating for example putting people on
buses
where you could have put let's say 55
people on a bus
and move them out you reduce that number
in half so that you can socially
distance them
which means it requires more vehicles um
it just takes longer
so there are many other factors that we
would do that we are doing now that we
didn't do for example during hurricane
harvey or previous storms
otherwise you can save people from
quote-unquote the storm
but you put them at even greater risk as
relates to the virus
either way if you get it and people have
underlying health conditions
you know you get sick in the hospital
you end up
dying you know it really doesn't make a
difference was the storm
or it was the virus and you mentioned
the importance of testing and i know
that you've
closed testing uh because of the
hurricane
are you concerned that a lack of testing
sites
could potentially increase the virus in
the area oh
absolutely testing is critical you know
for the
for the for the virus the testing gives
you if the testing is your radar
it helps you to identify where the virus
is
so we're having to deal with the virus
as well as with the storm at the same
time
in the absence of testing and i would
say ubiquitous widespread testing
it makes it very difficult to determine
the left of the prevalence of the virus
in your community
i was just on the phone with my um
health
director essentially saying look we
suspended testing for
thursday uh for wednesday and thursday
uh because we you know we didn't quite
know where the storm was going to be
coming
to the extent the storm bypasses uh a
stage to the east
you know we want to get testing up as
quickly as possible uh
and pro and and us uh we're looking to
see if we can get testing up on thursday
so we can get right back at it
and i also want to talk about your
message to residents who
are concerned about whether or not they
should be evacuating um what is your
message to them
well if you're alone that coastal area
quite frankly if you're a local
officials
uh uh uh intel tells you encourage
well number one if we issue a mandatory
evacuation you really need to evacuate
okay so that's number one number two if
we issue an inboun
a voluntary evacuation and you really
need to consider that
very strongly uh if you're along the
coast
okay and run the risk of being
in the area where that could be the
storm surge
uh then you seriously need to consider
evacuating
if your local officials tell you to do
just that
every storm is different and what we
have said to people as it relates to
hurricane laura
hurricane laura is different from
hurricane harvey
was primarily a rain event hurricane
lauren
is a her is a hurricane and for us
more like it's more of a wind and storm
surge event
so every every storm is different and
has its own different personalities
and so in this case with hurricane laura
if you're closer to the coastal area
within that
range of probability of being impacted
by storm surge
if there's a mandatory evacuation you
need to leave
if there's a voluntary evacuation you
need to take it very seriously
and to the extent you can leave you
ought to do just that
and talking about how the city more
broadly is doing uh the city's finances
were already
impacted by covet 19 we're threatened by
a fall off in tax revenue
stemming from the virus how much more of
a hit will
houston incur financially from things
like this hurricane
well look it complicates things even
more
um it certainly puts more of a financial
burden because we still need to meet the
needs of the people within our city
and quite frankly those who are visiting
our city anyone else within our city
we're responsible for um the corona
virus the fact the impact that has had
for example our sales tax
um parking fees you know in a number of
different areas
the city will be impacted for the next
two to three years okay
uh the the initial relief package we
received from the federal government
only really takes you really only deals
with primarily with testing
um and with uh taking steps to mitigate
the risk
of the coronal virus if what it was not
intended for example to replace the
whole
caused by the the um the reduction
of revenue as it relates directly from
the corona virus
and and congress has yet to come in to
assist
cities in filling that hole and we need
them to do that
but the reality is for example whether
it's the corona virus or whether it's
the storm
you see you're still you still need
police
you still need fire you still need your
municipal workers
uh solid waste uh picking up debris
your water systems public works whether
it's the virus
or the storm those essential services
cannot stop okay and you still and
cities are still responsible for
fulfilling those
obligations and when you combine the
coronavirus with the storm
then those responsibilities are
heightened okay
this is not the time to pull back cities
can't pull back
i need my employees out on the front
line
testing and other things with the virus
i need them out on the front line
when we're trying to make sure that we
evacuate to get him and get people out
of harm's way
they're needed on all fronts so i'm
especially appreciative and grateful
so in terms of the financial
hardship that this city is having to
experience
it is enormous and you do the best you
can
under the circumstances and we just we
continue every day to find a way to make
sure that we are meeting the needs of
the people who need us the very very
best
my hope is that congress
will not turn a blind eye
because quite frankly cities are on the
front
on the front line and you can't tell a
storm don't come your way
okay and you can't tell a virus because
look we
we have so many other needs you know
stop and go away
neither one of them neither one of them
will stop just because the city's
financial
uh uh situation is in doubt [ __ ]
mr mayor i know you have a very busy day
to get to but just following up on that
quickly um
are there any specific plans in place i
know you got out of a city council
meeting this morning
any plans that you all have talked about
on your end about
how you'll support residents financially
if their jobs or workplaces are
impacted by not only this hurricane but
we're
at the start of a hurricane season here
right so what i'll
continue i will tell you for people for
example who have lost their jobs have
been a fair load of their income and
revenues
streams have been reduced because of the
corona virus
right now as we speak the city has put
forth this
rental assistance program to provide
rental assistance for
for many of those individuals we have
partnered with many of our landlords
apartment complexes for example
and worked out an arrangement they're
saying look we're putting 20 million
dollars into a rental assistance program
for any apartment complex that agrees to
accept rental assistance even for one
for one tenant they are agreeing not to
evict
any of their tenants in their complex so
for example
if you have 200 units and if a tenant
and one of those units receive our
rental assistance
for two months one month whatever they
may be behind the the landlord is
agreeing not to evict
any of those 200 tenants in that
apartment unit
so i want to thank them for joining in
with us the second program that's going
on right now
about what is our small business
economic relief assistance
for small businesses if you've been in
business for example
for at least one year and if your
revenue
is 2 million and less for a year then
you are subject to
receiving a grant up to fifty thousand
dollars
from our small business economic relief
program those are two programs that are
currently in play
right now to assist our renters as well
as to assist our small businesses
the third program deals specifically
with artists so if you're an
artist and you too have been
economically
disadvantaged uh because of the
coronavirus then we have
a small program to assist
artists as well in making it through
this particular time
mr mayor i know you have to go but uh
one final question for you
um i want to ask you about jacob blake
what is your message to folks
who are reeling from yet another police
shooting in this country
you know it uh it's painful
all right it's you know it's uh
we're all wrestling with it you know
law enforcement and the community
should be on the same page working
together
moving in the same direction
you know the police shootings especially
when when the obligation is to protect
and and serve is certainly being tested
at this point in time
and every one of these shootings have to
be carefully examined
examined was certainly even in the city
of houston
we're looking at ways on how we can
reform for example
our police system looking at our
internal policies practices
and procedures emphasizing the
importance of de-escalation
emphasizing before using deadly force
where you can to provide a verbal
warning
making sure that officers are required
to report
or to intervene if another officer or
officers are doing something wrong
they have that obligation making sure
that every instance of deadly force
is reported establishing that database
that data system
eliminating no knock raids a warrant
for example those are things that we
have already implemented
and i have a task force right now that's
looking at
various ways on how to reform in a
meaningful way
law enforcement police our police
operation in our in our city
but police they're out there on the
front line
they have a hard job in many cases we
ask them to do way too much
but the situation is painful
my heart goes out for example uh to
jacob blake
and to his family i wish him well i'm
praying for him i know he's still
um going through surgeries and
experiencing a lot of pain and the
possibility of being paralyzed
so um look it's tough and it's
challenging but we have to find ways
uh to get things get it right because
the public
is certainly demanding us to get it
right and we have to get it right
and we need to get it right for our
police officers who are out there on the
front line
and for the people of that we have an
obligation to protect
and to serve so um we've got to continue
to work through it
and i believe if we do it and do it in
good faith i think we can end up with
some reforms
that will serve us well but now and for
years to come
mayor turner thank you so much you're so
generous uh with your time this
afternoon thank you for chatting with us
for those of you watching
please follow bloomberg quick take
wherever you get your news and thank you
so much for joining us
thank you thank you